Hey, what's going on? It's bill burn.
It's time for the Monday
morning podcast for April 2nd,
2018 what's going on?
How
welcome to April everybody. Oh, you
didn't think you'd make it, did you?
Oh the God damn snow just kept falling
out of the fucking sky and all these
fucking liberal concept talking
about global warming. Oh yeah,
I'll fucking cool you off when
my fucking toes. You can't. Um,
global warming.
I love on people who fucking,
when it snows in the winter,
people just go to global warming.
Um, I dunno bill, don't try
to be a scientist. Okay.
You've tried to be a lot of things
on this podcast and failed miserably.
Why would you pick such as smart vocation
to start off with? Well, you know,
cause I'm an arrogant ass.
Oh,
did I sleep well last night?
You know,
I uh, um, you know, I got my big,
big birthday coming up my 50th birthday.
So my deal was there's a certain weight
I wanted to get down to and a one of
those gene companies,
you know that advertise on my podcast,
I can't remember the fucking name of them.
It's one of those people, you know,
we were two broke college kids,
so we started a fucking Jean factory kits.
Like,
well how the fuck did you do that?
Thought you were broke.
You know, if you're trying to be all
down to earth and next thing you know,
you gotta you gotta fucking company.
What are you telling me?
You just sold them yourself.
Yeah,
we'll make you a pair of
pants set will be about a,
I don't know what we got to
learn how to sell first. Uh,
well cause we're Bronx sir.
We can't afford any sewing machines and
people that know how to operate them.
Okay.
Paulagy accepted and I'm sorry
too for yelling, but you know,
if you want jeans from us,
it's just going to take a moment.
Yeah.
So staying up on this thing so I can
measure your, do your inseam. Yeah.
So anyways,
they sent me a pair of jeans
that were a 30 to 32 would I,
you know, I was 34,
32. Uh, and now I'm 33,
32. So my, my goal is to get back to that.
I think that's the size that I had in
high school slash when I started, um,
started doing comedy. So I'll
see if I can, I don't know.
I don't know if I want to do that.
Cause you know,
this is one of those things
where like if your, uh, if your,
your high school weight when you're
my age, but you never really went up,
I don't think you look that bad.
But like if you get down to your high
school weight and you were actually like
an adult males weight, uh, you
kind of look like you're dying.
Okay.
Um, but we'll see. Uh,
I am back on my little health kick here.
Um, I told you last Monday, you know,
I did the goddamn comedy jam and,
um,
I had a shot at Jamison before the show,
you know, sort of a tradition, you know,
drink a little shot of fucking courage.
And then after the show I went out,
I was just going to have one
beer and it was going to go home,
but I showed up and somebody already
bought me another Jameson. So I had that.
And then I had a beer, but you know, the,
the shot and the beer was stretched
way out between the first,
like the whole show went
by like three hours. Um,
and I had a couple of
waters after the first shot,
so it was really just the
shot of Jameson in the beer.
And the next day I woke up. And, um,
aside from the fact that I stayed
out till one in the morning,
my lovely daughter gets up at like, oh,
six, six 30, I just woke up and I just,
I wasn't worth a shit until like
fucking two in the afternoon.
And, um, I was just like, I can't, I,
I can't do this.
I just can't fucking do this.
So I didn't drink
Tuesday, Wednesday, Thursday,
and then Friday I performed at arguably
my favorite theater in the country.
Um, the Brady theater and Tulsa, Oklahoma.
And it's,
I cannot expect fucking place and the
people that show up there and the way the
laugh sound in that room and the sound
and the look of that fucking place,
it's, it's unreal. The amount of
people too who've never been there.
When I told them I was going to Tulsa,
Oklahoma, they were like Tulsa, Jesus,
you know, thinking that it was going
to be like tumbleweeds and stuff.
It's a really fucking hipster replace.
Like the food scene alone
is crazy and you know when
the food is really good,
then you're going to have the record
store, which I liked the record store.
I don't necessarily like, you know, the
Douche is that go in there, you know,
I, you know, I'm a Douche to,
but like I was actually riffing about
that on stage where people like, dude,
it's sounds so much better.
It's like I can't hear the difference.
I can't hear that Daniel knew the CD was,
it was a lie man.
Everything got compressed and two,
they just get into a whole
fucking sound thing. And I'm just,
I just like records because they
reminded me when I was a kid, you know,
and you feel like you kind of got
more for your money. Well, you know,
you open it up and there was all these
pictures on the inside sleeve and all of
that shit. Um, I dunno.
As opposed to now you just download
it off off like iTunes and it's just
floating in the air man.
Um,
so anyways, I uh, so gifts getting
offstage that night, it was like,
I'm not going to drink.
And I just felt like, uh,
you know the habit of me doing
that being like, come on man,
just have fucking one.
Cause I was flying after the show.
It was like that show in Tulsa.
Every fucking reason why I
ever wanted to be a comedian.
It was so much fucking fun.
I was barely doing my act.
I forget what I did. Oh, I know why
I, I connected. I flew to Dallas,
connected there and then went up to Tulsa.
And um,
the second I got on the plane in Tulsa,
like there was just like three or
four really big people, you know,
not just fat but just big ass fucking
people. So I was just riffing on that.
One of them. Two people was so big
and fat they had to use wheelchair.
So I was just riffing on
the fact, you know? Yeah.
Are you really helping them out if you're
wheeling them around like a fucking
toddler and you know,
it's like,
I'm not trying to like
bring back segregation here,
but I really think wheelchairs to
just be for people who can't fucking,
whose legs don't work.
It's like your legs work,
you asshole lay off the cookies.
MMM.
I actually said you guys so fat that
even if he has a full head of hair,
you can still see most of his scalp. You
know, cause even that, it's just get,
even his head is getting like fat. It's
like stretching out. It was unbelievable.
This guy sat in the chair in
front of me and the fucking chair.
It was like coming down and it was one
of those things like an action movie,
like it's just going to fucking stop
or am I going to get crushed to death?
And it stopped about two inches
from the bridge of my nose.
I think I audibly exhaled like,
you know, cause it's like,
I mean, watching that guy tried to
get up, it'd be like my daughter,
she's still can't do like a sit up.
You know what I mean?
She just doesn't have the strength.
It's hilarious.
She gets like three inches up and she's
making this face and she's staring at
yeah. And then I just start laughing
and then she laughs, which, you know,
makes her fall back down again.
MMM.
So anyways,
she said Dad die now all the time,
but she was in the crib this morning and
I'm always the one that goes out and I
get her and then, uh, you know,
pick her up and I figured out, because
she gives the best hugs, but she's also,
you know, a toddler now, so she
just wants to look at everything.
So when she says she only
does it for half a second.
So the way to trick her into giving
you a nice minute long hug it,
she got to sing to her and she loves sea
itsy bitsy spider right now like that.
That's your fucking jam,
right?
So I just come out there
and she's like, hi, hi.
Hi. Hi. You know, showing off the
word that she knows how to say.
And then I just pick her up and she gives
me the quick hug and then immediately
is pointing over to the
changing table cause you know,
she wants to get that over with so she
could then go in and watch a little
cartoons, you know, and drink
a bottle of milk. Right.
That I got it down now I just
pick her up and I just go,
oh the itsy bitsy spider went up.
The water spout.
Dow came though Ray,
they're wise to spider out and by,
she's already later head. I
sing. It's sweeter than that.
I kind of pushed through with you guys,
didn't want to creep you out,
but she fucking uh,
puts their head down on my shoulder.
It just sits,
there is content.
I could sing the song like six times
in a row and she'll just lay there.
And then when I get sick of that song,
I just sing the abcs and uh,
and did she does this thing, if you
squeeze her and you go give me a hug,
her too little fat hands.
She grabs two handfuls of your shirt.
That's fucking adorable.
Um,
I'm starting to realize why dad's
cry at their daughter's wedding.
You know, I used to do, I think
it was some weird shit though.
They would just like thinking
like, oh, this guy is good.
Even if even if they haven't
already bagged, he's got a
banger now tonight. Yeah.
Oh God, you pluck an ass hole. And I got
to pretend like I like, um, you know,
thinking like that shit. It isn't,
they're thinking about the Etsy be like,
I used to sing this kid, the
itsy bitsy spider, you know,
where did the fucking decades
go? So anyways, going back to my,
uh, you know, the booze
and, and shit like, um,
I dunno. So then, uh, you know, that man,
it's like that's already going to be the
greatest moments in my life are going
to be those and I just don't want to be
all banged up and extra tired and God
forbid grumpy. So, um,
I dunno. So then San
Antonio, I did two shows,
fucking amazing crowds down there.
Um,
and once again I just carried
over whatever happened in Tulsa.
Uh,
I've learned how to do that though,
as far as like what happens as you know,
when you go out on one night,
you just in the zone and you're not even
doing your act the next night you come
on stage,
you're like hoping that you're going to
be in the zone again the night before.
You weren't hoping that you were going
to be in the zone. It just happened.
So then you going out there and now
you're hoping it's going to be like last
night. So now you're walking on stage
and you're thinking about last night.
So you're not,
you're not like mentally,
they're not to get all trippy.
So what I do is I try to
let go of the last night,
but do the same fucking
thing that I did in that.
I'll just talk about something that I
just fucking saw except this time it's in
San Antonio.
And I just came out and I was bitching
about the fact that I didn't realize that
the final fucking for
Pfoa was in San Antonio.
I kind of figured it out when it was 500
bucks a night at a Goddamn red roof inn
bought up by the fucking airport.
Um,
and then it was just like this going to
be a real problem with transportation.
I had to hire this company,
you know,
to make sure they get picked me
up the airport. Get Dean, you,
it was out there with del Rio del rape.
Fucking murdered so hard in Tulsa.
He had a sustained round of applause.
Like he had to wait
before he introduced me.
That's how fucking hard
this guy's killing.
So you got to go see dean
when he's out in the road.
Actually watch them do like a full set.
I know he has an album coming out to uh,
on vinyl, I believe,
speaking of records. So, um,
anyways,
I went out and just did the same thing
and on both shows I just, you know,
fucked around and rift about some shit
and it just got me into this place.
And then it was fun cause I was,
you know,
both nights I was teasing people about
having an ar fifteens and telling them
how they should go about talking to people
on the left about why you have an ar
15. And um, it just,
it just was a fucking great night
both nights. So what does my point?
So my point is, I just, you know, through,
I was watching the Zen
diaries of Garry Shandling,
this fucking incredible
documentary that Judd Apatow did.
Um, and it is such the standup
comedian he experience,
I literally had to take breaks from it.
I had to shut it off or hit pause.
I'd be watching the thing right.
And I would just,
something he would write down because
Gary I guess kept all these diaries and
stuff and judge just,
we'll just like film like just
a line or two that he wrote.
And uh,
it would either be something that I
thought or something that I never realized
and it's just like, yeah, that's it.
Or just an experience that I had and
obviously all my experiences are in a way
less like whatever experience he had at
the tonight show or hosting the Emmy's.
I had plane,
you know,
uncle fuckees and you know
that Swampscott Massachusetts.
Um, but I just kept fighting. I would
be watching this. She was hilarious.
It'd be watching the show and he would
be like in the other room and then she
just hit me in the other
room just going like, ah,
and
um,
just watching how the way
this thing is put together,
I'm not going to ruin it for you.
But just seeing how,
like one like major event,
when you're a kid with
your developing mind,
be it positive or negative,
how it just shapes and informs the rest
of your life and the way that it is done
is so fucking masterful in
this documentary. And um,
I don't know, I just can't
say enough things about it. So
I was sitting there after having watched
it, or actually I'd watched up to the,
like the first half hour of part two.
I mean,
it's like four and a half hours
long and it's fucking amazing.
And I was actually out on the road going,
fuck,
I wish I could watch the
rest of that right now. You
know, it's just, you know, I,
it's hard to find four and a half
hours when you got, you know,
you've got a 14 month old
to just sit down in a row.
So I was out there and I was
just thinking about, you know,
I was mad at myself that and went
out after Tulsa and I had a drink.
I had one drink and then
somebody sent one over to me.
And of course I'm going to drink that
cause they didn't want to be rude and you
know,
I'm a bit of a Booze Hound and um,
I kinda just was sticking
to myself. Like, uh,
I told myself I wasn't going to drink
until fucking June and I already fucked up
on the road. Not even cause I wanted
to just started like, you know,
I'm flying high and fucking wide awake.
I don't want the night to end,
you know, um, to awake to
fucking go is still to sleep.
I got an 8:00 AM flight,
let me just fucking have one.
And then next thing you know,
I'm fucking staying out till
like one in the goddamn morning.
I gotta get up at six for the
flight is what am I doing?
I should be out here getting
sleep for when I come back.
So I going to be a better dad. This is
stupid. So, because I watched, you know,
at that point,
the first half of the zen diary thing,
I actually had a notebook because I was
writing out some of the drum parts for
these songs. I got to sing with
Dell Rake, not saying sorry,
play on Tuesday night out
here at the Avalon. And uh,
I was just like, why don't
you just write down, you know,
these goals? Cause sometime if he,
sometimes if you just fucking think them,
they're not real and then I feel
Sam or write them down anyways,
how my brain works,
it becomes real.
So I just kind of wrote it down the
shit that I wanted to do, you know,
the shape I wanted to be in and
yeah,
I just wrote down that I was just for
the month of April. I'm just like,
I'm not smoking any fucking cigars.
I'm not drinking any booze.
Um, you know, not
watching any fucking porn,
you know,
fucking stupid online porn,
lonely shit you do on
the road and that porno,
I swear to God it's going to come out
like how bad that is for you, your brain,
you know what I mean? Cause I find
myself now when I watch porno laughing,
like I'm watching a sitcom,
it's always something that just
strikes me is fucking funny. Um,
yeah. And it's just like, I
shouldn't be laughing while
was this, this weird. Right.
And then you also think
like, you know, you go back,
I don't know how many fucking years,
like if you went back like a hundred years
and you showed somebody like a laptop
and be like, yeah, you realize you can
watch this and you just put it on the,
I swear to God, they would burn you at
the stake. Lik you were a fucking, which
like how fucked up it would be that a
human being could sit down anytime they
wanted and just watch endless
hours of that shit. Um,
I bet I did some brain damage. Something.
It's like you fucking, it's like you, I,
I really feel like, um, um,
destroying my soul by watching that shit
on some level. So I was
like, good to not do that.
I'm going to fucking continue to work out
all of these, just sort of these, these,
these,
I dunno,
health goals and then I
got to work on my, my, uh,
my anger issues because my daughter
doesn't realize I have them yet and it's
just inevitable. She's going to,
I've been doing this joke on my act,
how it likes a couple of times
she seen me start to slice. She,
she honestly hasn't even met me
yet as far as like who I really am.
She's met the side of
me that I'm proud of,
but all this shit that I'm ashamed of,
she hasn't really met yet.
She's seen a couple of glimpses, but I'm
always able to joke my way out of it.
Like, Oh Daddy, always through
the laptop through the Weirdo.
She's laughing because she doesn't
know what those words mean or that,
that behavior is fucked
up. Right. So I dunno,
that's just shit I have to
work on. So, uh, I don't know.
I don't think I would have written that
down and it would have become real had I
not watched that. Uh, Zen diaries,
a Gary Shayla, I'm telling man,
you gotta you gotta fucking see
that thing and speaking the way HP,
I was killing it this month
because they have like a,
they got one on a documentary on like
Andre the giant, Martin Luther King.
Um, Elvis. I mean they just, I mean,
and I think it comes out every Wednesday.
So if you're not watching the NHL
rivalry fucking Wednesday, uh,
or even if you are just tape some of
these things, because you know, HBO,
they always do everything
fucking top shelf. It's going
to be amazing. So anyways,
I have some things to, uh, have
I made you guys laugh once yet?
I've just been fucking being an
idiot here talking about this shit,
but it's also, I just feel
like I'm doing is very me. Um,
all right. I've got a couple
of announcements here. One,
I'm transitioning. Okay. Uh,
October six, 2018 I'm going to
be in Bridgeport, Connecticut.
All right. At Webster Bank arena. Uh,
general public on sale will be Friday,
April 6th at noon.
April six one I'm gonna be in
Pittsburgh for two shows. Um,
what an idiot.
Then people are not going to be there.
I'm really hyping other shows. I'm
trying to hype this new one. October 6th,
2018 Bridgeport, Connecticut,
Webster Bank arena.
General public on sale will be Friday,
April 6th at noon.
The presale starts
today. Today. All right,
the code is Billy Baldwin.
You get it Billy bald
when all capital letters,
no spaces.
B I l L Y B a l d for The win win.
Um, anyways, you know, it
was fucking hilarious. I,
I did the Brady theater in Tulsa.
I pull up and uh,
this is one dude standing outside,
you know,
the fucking, the stage door. All
right. And uh, I got to sing.
I hate meeting people before the show,
after the show, I don't give a fuck,
but before the show, I, I can't,
it's just, it's weird to me.
It's like I haven't done
my fucking thing that I do.
So, um, I'm thinking about
doing that. You know, I don't,
I, I I no problem after,
before it just weirds me out.
So I go to it and this guy
goes, he's like, yeah, hey bill,
a big fan of getting mega good gum.
I,
I go to sign his fucking shit and all of
a sudden I feel like this sticky thing,
like I had like syrup
in my hand or something.
I handed back to Penn and I looked down
at my fucking hand is just co cop might
get the ink,
the pen exploded.
Okay.
Oh fuck.
I look like I don't know what I look like.
So I walk in and it's really like thick.
Okay.
Like black or blue ink.
I went in the bathroom and I'm like trying
to scrub the skin off my fucking hand.
Yeah.
And um, you know, del Ray's laughing
at me and shit, look at literally shit.
You know, my hands are so pasty, so I got
this, it's like my cancer in black face,
right.
So I'm fucking scrubbing the shit off
and I was able to get most of it off,
but there's still like, you know,
you can see the stain of it. MMM.
I wish I talked about that
when I went out on stage. Um,
but I did.
So I went out and I did the show.
And as I go to walk off the stage,
who comes walking down to the front of
the stage, hey bill, but blah, blah, blah,
blah. I already met here.
I already signed you shit.
And I already got the egg all over
my hair, but he's getting married.
So going over Shay, man,
thank you. I go, you know,
good luck with your
marriage and everything.
Okay.
So that I fucking walk out.
Right.
Okay.
Just talking to Dana. I'm like, Dude,
how fucking unbelievable is that theater?
You'd say, Oh, you know, the
sound is unbelievable crab
about blah. You know, Dean,
that show was fire,
right? So we go outside
and uh, we go to leave the places
like 10 or 15 people there, right?
So I'm fucking day guys, thanks for
coming out, talk to people, you know,
signing shit or whatever and this fucking
guy comes up again and he wants me to
sign more shit.
And I'm thinking in my head,
it's just like this flickers guy coming
back from fucking second. So mean,
why did you, you know,
there's other people here.
We already did this and I shook your hand.
So I got to sign something fucking else.
Study has and I feel this sticky thing.
He gave me the same fucking 10 again
and I was so stupid that I went and I
grabbed the thing and I just like that.
Yeah, you fucking asshole. You Go,
you've got an exploded pen here.
And then he just starts laughing.
Yeah.
And now I got to shit on my fucking
hand, my hands, all the exact same,
almost exact same fingers and all that.
Obviously I'm not ambidextrous switching
my hands and I'm just like in Dean's
fucking ned deed signed something,
forms we bowls,
walked back into the fucking car,
we got ink all over our hands and the
drivers laughing his ass off at us because
he saw me when I went in and go that
fucking asshole. It exploded pen.
So as this is the thing,
as I go to get in the car,
this same dude who I already signed,
his shit, got ink on my hand,
shook his head after the fucking
show. You know, as a walking offstage,
shook his hand, sign more, shit, got
more fucking exploded in my hand.
Even when goes, he goes, hey bill,
did you go to a Po address that I could
send these six to these pictures I took
on his cell phone. I just
go, now you fucking asshole.
I got a call over my hand again.
And he just starts laughing.
Then they felt bad and go,
good luck with your marriage.
Yeah,
we get in,
the cars would drive it away and I just
was just riffed about the poor woman
that is going to marry that fucking guy,
you know?
Cause it was something about them.
You couldn't get mad at him.
But I really think that that
exploding pen was a fucking omen,
you know, that he was just
going to be like, I dunno.
Jesus Christ. So anyways, I um,
let me read a little bit of advertising
and then I'll tell you about San Antonio
going down there with the final
four experience going on. Um,
where the hell is it? What do we got
here? What do we got this week? Oh,
it don't cheat.
Oh,
talk about how a made to measure suit
fits compared to a generic off the rack
suit. Well, unless you're like
a generic off the rack size,
I imagine your ankles are going to be
showing and your balls are going to be
snugged or uh,
you know,
you're going to be looking like you have
your big brother's pants on if you're a
little shorty.
Yeah,
I mean obviously do I really need to
explain to people that if they actually
take your fucking measurements, I
mean, if they take your measurements,
it's going to fit
okay
the way it's supposed to fit it on.
All of a sudden women are going
to be looking at you like, Oh,
who's that guy look at all fucking sharp
in his suit as opposed to trying to hit
the lottery and being like, you know,
did the, the, the, the, the, the, the,
the fucking person in El Salvador
that sell this together. You know,
it was he the same size as me.
Guys love the wide selection of high
quality fabrics and the option to
personalize all the details,
including your lapel lining and monogram
as kind of cool that you can pick out
your own, the pel and aligning. All right,
so later on that night,
you know,
and you're on your date and you'd take
your jacket off and you fucking put it
around the back of the chair. You
get a little flash, their monogram,
you taking yourself seriously. All of a
sudden the woman thinks you're fucking,
you're running something. Um,
back when guys used to go buy a,
you know, by the initial, this is an
h g wells. Say, here's how it works.
Visit a show room or shop
online@indochino.com pick your fabric,
Tujia customizations,
submit your measurements,
weight for your custom suit to arrive.
And just a few weeks after, fuck,
okay,
I need a suit for the
rough and rowdy thing.
I should have ordered one through them
anyways.
This week,
my listeners can get any premium Indochino
suit for just 379 bucks@indochino.com
when entering burr at checkout,
that's 50% off the regular price for
a made to measure premium suit plus
shipping is free.
That's indochino.com promo
code [inaudible] for any
premium suit for just 379
bucks and free shipping.
Incredible deal for a suit that will fit
you better than anything off the rack
ever could. Well, I'm looking for a unique
suits to wear at these rough and rowdy.
Thanks. Alright, so maybe I'll
go through these guys, you know,
provided everything. I just think
everything's going to go well at this,
provided the people at Barstool.
Want me to come back for the next one?
Cause I'm already,
I'm already ready to come back for the
fucking next one and I haven't even been
to this one yet. And it's on April
13th in Charlotte, North Carolina.
Okay. Um, it's, it's
gotta be on pay per view.
I believe it's like 16 bucks.
It's the biggest no brainer. Ever.
Get your friends over,
sit down and just watch regular
people talk shit and go in the ring.
It, it just fucking wail
on each other. It's,
it's the greatest fucking idea.
I Dunno.
Every once in a while I, I know I keep
saying this, but you know, I'm so site,
I'm gonna have a ringside seats that we
sit and rig side for the whole fucking
thing. That'll be another
added thing cause I don't know,
I don't know how to commentate.
I'm not Joe Rogan. Joe Rogan is,
is borderline of fucking Moussad agent.
Yeah.
Okay.
With his abilities and his understanding
of combat. Me On the other hand,
[inaudible] just going to sound
like I was just some loud shithead.
Sit next to you on your couch. Okay.
That's what I'm gonna do. Alright.
MVMT movement.
Uh,
here's my problem with
sunglasses. I didn't know I
had a problem with sunglasses.
Why are you putting words in my mouth?
I got all these cheap pairs that look
terrible. No, I don't. I am nice pairs.
Okay.
But every time I buy 200, $200
pair, I feel like I get ripped off.
That's not what I feel. Here's
my problem with sunglasses, okay?
If you buy a fucking cheap pair,
they don't do anything.
You still squinting behind them.
Now your face is all mushed
up wearing sunglasses.
You look like a fucking asshole and
they're digging into the right above your
ear on your scalp.
But then if you buy a nice expensive pair,
then you got to sit there going like,
oh my God. Oh my God, what if I,
what if I lose it? What if I sit on, I'm
in. And inevitably that fucking habits.
Okay, movement. That's what I
feel about fucking sunglasses.
How dare you put words in my mouth.
Okay.
And I don't feel like I got ripped off.
If I pay $200 I feel like a fucking
asshole when I lose them. All right,
well our friends at movement.
Yeah,
the watch guys, they kind
of felt the same way. Oh,
I didn't know if they agreed with
me. So they, they thought screw it.
I think they thought fuck it.
How about we make quality
trendy glasses at a fair price?
These things aren't plastic.
They acetate.
You can get them polarized.
Is that a word?
As [inaudible] tape?
I gotta add that word.
I'm going to fuck it.
I'm a S. I would have,
it's a goal of mine today to
throw that word in with my wife.
Okay.
See what the fuck.
What the fuck does that mean?
Okay.
Do, do you ever go look up a
fucking word on Wikipedia? What?
What is that writing when you're
trying to figure out how to spell it.
It looks like it's in Russian.
Yeah.
Is it is a salt form by a combination of
Seti acidic acid with an alkaline,
earthy,
metallic base of, fuck this. I don't give
it. I don't need to know what it means.
I just know how to say it.
Nobody knows.
Nobody knows what this fucking word means.
You just say it and people like, wow,
that guy's guy's smart. Look at that.
Look at his custom lining on a suit.
All right, here we go. Ready
everybody. This is thing. Okay.
If you're a supported this podcast,
you have to work this word
into your day with somebody.
Who would you that you know very well?
Who's going to know that you have no idea
what this fucking word means and your
goal is to try and fucking play it off.
Like you've always had
this in your arsenal,
like this was part of your fucking
pitching rotation. Here we go.
Come on,
say it.
Acetate,
acetate.
You're fucking
acetate
now you go kind of sounds like asshole,
doesn't it? You fucking acid tape acetate
to how creepy is this?
This is like,
it's the end of the world and that's
like some morning and the future.
You know.
Everybody get the fuck out of here.
You're correct.
I think we just lost Mike.
All right. Sorry about that.
Uh, that was my, my version of like alien.
All you need in the background
that acetate. Acetate. Yeah.
Oh God.
What's going on here?
Acetate affects oil.
I like learning stuff when they,
when they have music that makes
you not think that's an a ship.
Hi Stanford.
Welcome to has gotta be the
worst fucking fade down ever.
Have anything,
wasn't it
high? Stampers love them too.
I'm like, crap. Jesus Christ.
How about a nice little fade downs,
your hey stampers and today I'm going to
teach you about how acetate acetate in
the future.
Someday when you're dumb enough to buy
a fucking robot one day when it has a
glitch and you come walking in there and
it has an even weirder robot expression
on his face and you're like,
ah, hey, what's up there?
Fucking r two d two and it's just
looking at you going Acetate,
Acetate, acetate. Why?
Why are you saying that man? Like
slowly walking towards you acetate. Um,
anyways, what the fuck was I
talking about? So sunglasses,
they have lots of styles to choose from.
Wait,
these things aren't plastic.
They acetate.
Okay.
Acetate,
acetate.
You can get them polarized
and they start at just $70.
There is seriously my goto shades.
I don't even have a fucking pair yet.
Send them to me. I want
these six. Hey Bill,
what'd you get those sunglasses.
I'm just going to stare at them like
the fucking terminator. Awesome state.
Awesome.
They are high quality premium Acetate,
Acetate,
acetate frames,
no cheap plastic here.
You got to see these.
They have lots of styles to choose
from. Classic, Trendy, round.
A Va mirrored polarized.
I love guns.
Fuck it.
That's polarized for him and for her.
You're sure to find the perfect pair.
Get 15% off today with free shipping and
free returns by going to mvmt.com/burr
you know about movement for how they've
Rebelo revolutionize the watch industry.
They've already done that.
This is like a fighter that's
moving up in weight class.
They already got that belt.
Now they're going to go for the next one.
Now's the time to check
out their sunglasses.
Go to movement.com/burr
that's m v as in Victor,
m t as in toodaloo.com/bird.
Join the movement,
acetate acetate beyond these everybody.
Oh, here we go. Boto doot,
doot me undies me undies.
Nice soft shit against you taint. But
Dude, dude, dude, me undies me undies,
they don't fucking acid taint.
Why would you want that shit up against
your skin? Especially down there.
There is no win.
Wash it off with your ladies face.
Sorry,
you've,
you've heard me talk about me undies
and you know that I'm a big believer and
their product, they're the perfect
balance of comfort and fit.
Every month they have new and exciting
prints and they arrive at your door in a
fun bag. Um, yeah,
they sent me another sack on to where
one of them were like referee shorts.
I didn't know how I felt about those.
It's like,
what am I gonna fucking be rat and keep
the lot now throwing flags and stuff. Uh,
me undies uses Lenzing micro micromolar.
What the fuck is Lenzing Lenzing
Lenzing in their underwear.
It's sustainably sourced. What
does that mean? They can grow more?
Are they planting Lenzing
micromolar modelle trees?
Naturally soft fiber that starts with
beechwood trees and ends with the most
amazing fabric you've ever experienced.
How the fuck he cut down a tree and
make comfortable underwear? It's just,
just goes to show you the level of genius.
Although if you had to like,
you know,
put your under carriage up
against the tree, I think, uh, uh,
beechwood tree would
probably be the nicer one.
You know it's got this smooth bark,
right?
The results have been downright dreamy.
Me undies adventurous,
printed designs are all limited edition
and new patterns are released every few
weeks on a rolling basis.
100% satisfaction guarantee me undies
guarantees you will love their undies or
your money back beyond.
These has a great offer for my
listeners for any part time.
First Time purchasers,
when you purchase any me undies,
you get 20% off and free shipping.
B and gs is so sure you'll
love their underwear.
They offer a hundred percent
satisfaction guarantee.
If you don't love your first pair, you'll
get a full refund. This is a no brainer.
Get uh,
get 20% off a pair of the most comfortable
underwear you will ever put on.
Do you hear somebody screaming?
Okay.
Oh,
she's got the cartoons on.
Some weird lady came in the
fucking room in the house.
I mean not to get 20% off your
first pair of free shipping.
100% satisfaction guarantee.
Go to [inaudible] dot com slash bird
that's [inaudible] dot com slash burn hang
on a second. I've got to go to turn that
down a little bit. Little bit. Little bit,
yeah.
Hey ladies.
Wow. Can you guys just turn
it down just a little bit
in front of Acetate my podcast.
Oh, sorry. I'm good. I'm just trying
to ask you to take this thing here.
You get it done. All right. What's
that? You don't know what assets savings
he,
I don't know if you could hear that.
I used acetate like two or three
times and she just looks up. She goes,
I don't know what that word means
and I don't care too. So that you go,
that's right. You know that's
a good one to use on your lady.
She'll think that you fucking
moving on, you know, is he,
is he getting smart as the tape?
Get the fuck off me.
See right there.
That's what I want to work on my temper.
I was just literally trying to bring the
cord around my foot and I couldn't do
it because I'm not flexible enough
and I just said get the fuck off me.
Like it was a person.
Is something wrong about that?
Um,
all right.
stamps.com stamps.com brings all the
amazing services of the U S Post Postal
Service right to your fingertips.
Buy and print official US postage
for any letter, any package,
any class of mail using your own computer
and printer stamps.com makes it easy.
They'll send you a digital scale.
Automate automatically calculates exact
postage stamps.com we'll even help you
decide the best class of
mail based on your needs.
No need to lease an
expensive postage meter. Uh,
and there are no long term commitments.
I use stamps.com because,
um, uh, I dunno why use
it cause you fucking,
you buy advertising on this
thing and I ended up using it.
It turned out to be easy,
but I'll be, I, you know,
I did it for the money man and
then it turned out to be a great,
great thing and I don't have to go to the
post office when I send out my fucking
posters. All right. Anyways, uh,
and right now you too can enjoy stamps.
The stamps.com service with a special
offer that includes a four week trial plus
postage and a digital scale.
Go to stamps.com click on the microphone
at the top of the homepage and type in
bird. That's stamps.com
enter [inaudible]. Um,
all right, what else did
I want to talk about? Oh,
another thing with that Gary Shandling
think that that documentary really
affected me was,
you know,
one of the things that happens
to a lot of comedians is, uh,
whatever the fuck happened to us
that made us become comedians. Uh,
you just start chasing,
you know,
selling out clubs and get known
and becoming famous and all that,
and thinking that that's going to fucking,
you know,
get rid of your demons
and, uh, it doesn't.
And then you put off
the major party of life,
which is finding love and starting
a family and all of that shit.
And, um, you know,
the other day I was talking to somebody
and they were in their early thirties,
and I brought up the Garry Shandling
documentary and the person said,
who's that? Right? And
then I also mentioned like,
uh, somehow I brought up Robin Williams
and I mentioned that he had, you know,
committed suicide a few years in and
she didn't even realize he was dead.
And she was just like, Mrs Doubtfire.
And I was like, in my head,
I'm just going to, these
people are fucking legends.
And it's just like, you know,
every generation has their people,
you know what I mean? So it's like,
it was like so fucking profound.
What's like,
you chasing all of that fucking
shit. And you know, once you,
once you're past a certain nick, no one's
going to give a shit anymore anyways.
So it's like you're trying to,
I dunno,
it's not like a tangible
thing that you can depend on.
And I had this big fear when I was
going through comedy that I was like,
uh, I was like, Oh man,
am I gonna be the guy that doesn't
get married and never has kids?
Because I've seen the other side of that
as like, I don't want to fucking, yeah,
I don't want to end up being that cliche.
And then just being in that fucking,
that older fucking comic,
you know,
and then you got you sport coat on to
hide your middle and you're talking to,
if you're talking at this point,
you're hitting on women that don't know
who your bands are and don't know all,
all,
all your cultural references.
They don't even know who these fucking
people are and the level of fucking
sadness that the, how lonely that feeling
would be at. I used to fucking wake up,
I didn't literally wake up,
but I would be laying in bed on the
road thinking about shit like that.
And when I was watching this
documentary, I remember, you know,
thinking, uh, as I was watching
Gary wrestling with his demons,
I literally said to Nia one point, I
was like, marrying you and having a kid.
He's the smartest fucking thing I ever
did. Thank God. I know I did it late,
but thank God I fucking did that
because if I didn't, you know,
I'd be 70 years old in some fucking God
damn hotel on the other side of this
shit when nobody gave a fuck.
And I would just be laying there
drinking myself to death going Acetate,
acetate.
That literally makes me scared
just saying that acetate. Um,
anyways, so, uh, I think what
I'm gonna do, cause I don't
think I'm a diary person,
but I think,
but I'm going to do is I'm just going to
kind of write down in the beginning of
the day, just I find it
just one day of doing that.
It's really vivid and lives now rather
than just being this fucking random
thought. Like, you know,
I need to work on this.
Maybe just have a fucking
goal each day. So my kid, uh,
I can kind of kill off this fucking anger
demon that exists in my family tree.
I would love to see my family tree.
It's got to look like a,
that'd be this weird combination
of like, oh, that's really nice,
but a little upsetting.
You know,
like a tree in the beginning of winter,
um,
at a certain time of
day, you know, you know,
that certain time of day
would trees are beautiful,
but they start to look a little ominous.
That's probably what it would look like.
Uh, a tree that's trying.
All right. Let's, uh,
oh,
I didn't tell you guys about my
fucking journey back from San Antonio.
So, uh, I had a 6:00 AM flight
to Tulsa, Oklahoma. You know,
I normally I would have flown in the
night before, but I got the kid, you know,
I can't, can't miss those
hours. So I flew in, no problem.
Everything was great.
The next day I had an 8:00 AM flight to
San Antonio for whatever fucking reason.
I mean, it's not that long a flight.
We're in the same time zone. Wow.
How come I couldn't get like
the 10 o'clock flight? Right?
So we check into the hotel, we
do the show, everything's great.
And then the next morning I had a 6:00
AM flight and I got off stage of 12 and
couldn't get to sleep till like
one 32 in the morning. So, uh,
it was just like, all right,
I'll just sleep on the plane.
So we get up at like four
30 in the fucking morning,
quarter to five go down there.
And my big thing is when I
only get like two hours sleep,
all I'm trying to do is get on the plane
and once I get on the fucking plane
it's like I'm just going to go to sleep.
You know,
I forgot my eye mask and one can't always
has to have their fucking shade up,
you know, cause they're a morning
person and fuck everybody else.
You know no consideration for somebody
who just fucking stop working at,
you know, 12 1230 right. So we get there
and I'm laughing at dean cause
we are like so fucking tired.
It's like you literally like
you're hung over or like food.
All I gotta do is get on
that plane and he's like,
I know I'm going to go right to sleep
and then I'm going to land at seven 30 la
time. Right. By the time I get to my
fucking house, it's going to be eight 30.
My daughter just got up a half hour early.
I'm going to get that whole time with
her before she does her first nap.
Fucking perfect. Um, and all
of a sudden they're like, uh,
the flights now going to fucking
leave at six 15. You know,
cause they said they had
to reset the airplane,
which I don't know what the fuck that
means. Is that some computer shit?
I have no idea. And then six 15
became six 45 and I was like, Oh God,
don't do this.
Please don't do this.
And then it became seven 45 and
then it got fucking canceled.
And then because it was the final four,
all the fucking planes was sold out.
And the next one they
could get us on was 7:00 PM
and I was like trying to keep my cool,
which of course I didn't.
And they said, sir, it's okay.
We're going to send everybody
on the seven o'clock flight.
We're going to send on an excursion
today, paid by Delta. I'm like,
I don't want to go on an excursion. I
want to go to Los Angeles. And she goes,
they're going to take you to world.
It's like, Oh yeah, I think in it.
Buy me a giant fucking lollipop.
I don't want to fucking,
I don't want to watch an incarcerated
killer whale doing fucking jumping through
a hula hoop. Okay. I don't want to see
that. What I would like, can I go there?
And once you set that
fucking thing free again,
I would see that that would be worth it.
You know,
watch a jump over a little boy is it goes
out out of the bay into a fucking the
ocean like free willy.
Um,
so anyways, so we say Fuck Delta, not
fucked delta. Literally fucked Delta,
but fuck this situation delta put us in.
Cause I know all the airlines this,
it's just a, hey, it happens. Okay. The
fucking planes not working right. I it,
but I'm also frustrated. So I go down to
southwest, all of this shit is filled up.
Um, so we're like, what about Dallas?
Can you fly us to Dallas love field
and we'll just fly back. Can't do that.
Um, and then we just say, what about
Austin? And they go, okay, well Austin,
we have a 10:00 AM flight at
this point. It's like, you know,
getting close to nine. We have an 11 and
we have a two 15. So I'm like, all right,
put us on the fucking two 15 and you know,
it's an hour and a half drive.
So Dean goes to get a fucking
rental car. And I said, fuck this,
let's just Uber then we don't have to
deal with picking up the rental car,
the shuttle and all that.
So we did fucking ubered.
I passed out in the fucking car,
I got out of the car,
I left my fucking headphones in that,
this is my third time.
Second Time I've lost those
Bose headphones. Um, I always
keep the charge of the,
if anybody has a set of
those silver fucking bows or
the black ones and you need
that little charger cord, uh, send me
your address and I'll mail it to you.
Um, cause I'm going to have three of them
is I just ordered another fucking pair.
So anyways,
uh,
we get out and we got there so fucking
fast cause there was no traffic.
We actually got on the 1115 had to
connect through fucking Phoenix.
It wasn't that bad and uh,
it all worked out. And uh,
and because I had written down that Shit,
you know,
that I want it to like maybe talk to
somebody about my temper or something like
that.
Um,
I was actually completely aware that I
was fucking snapping when I snapped like
that. That's as far as I've ever been
able to get to with my temper. You know,
the old new,
I would just snap and not think about it.
Now I'm actually thinking about it as
I do it and have no control over it.
So it's even more like torturous now
because now like watching myself, ah,
you go bill yelling at people that like
build, they're trying to save your life.
Do you think they're not flying because
they want to go through this giant
fucking headache?
On some level,
they're probably losing money because
one of their planes cannot fly.
Would you like to get up to a cruising
altitude and then plunge back to the
fucking earth and never
see your family again? Oh,
Boohoo you have to wait 12
hours to continue living.
He was selfish, stupid cunt.
Um,
but I can't hear anything at that point.
I'm in the fucking acetate mode.
Um, are, I'm killing that joke. Uh,
by the way, um, I am so
back into def Leppard now.
It's ridiculous. I downloaded pyromania
and uh, what was it? High and dry,
the one before that. And
uh, I'm so into them.
I'm actually looking at
lefthanded flying V's, you know,
like maybe this is the guitar. I'll know
how to fucking, I'll actually stick with,
um, cause I was just watching their
lineup. But what's that guy's name?
Pete Willis is the guy that the
head on the, on the high and dry.
And then they had, um, what's
his face filled in for him? Uh,
I always forget his fucking name and
it's literally the same name as somebody
else. Famous. It's Phil
Collins, not Phil Collins.
He came in and filled in form.
Um, but like that, that album,
uh,
pyromania when that came out,
that's just one of those albums that came
out during this awesome time and your
life.
Um,
first time he had crushes on
fucking chickson you're graded shit.
And that fucking album came
out, you know, and I did the,
and this is what I would do rather than
thinking, what can I say to this chicken,
my fucking class that I like this lady,
I would actually just,
I would just go home instead and I would
listen to Pyromania fantasizing that I
was in the band playing the guitar
and singing in front of the school.
And even in the fantasies,
she would just see me do it and
I would still never talk to her.
I'm a fucking mess. Um, and that's what
leads you. Then they'd just say, well,
I can't sing and I can't play guitar.
I guess I'll go up there and
tell shit jokes. I guess.
Thank day time I became a comedian.
All right. Rough and rowdy.
Charlotte April 13th.
Billy's going to wear a fucking silly
suit and he's going to fucking make some
jokes. You got to watch it. Pay per
view. Uh, all right. F One dear.
Silly Billy. Greetings from Monaco. Oh,
the sovereign state on the French
Riviera originally from Portugal.
I'm a very big f one fan since
I was four years old. Well,
it seems like you saw the hay day of it,
the second golden age of it
with Michael Schumacher. Uh,
my grandfather says I wouldn't take my
eyes off the cars even if a storm took
the roof off the house.
It's a beautiful and graceful
sport despite how loud it can be.
I first saw you from Chappelle and then
saw you on an interview on the Internet
from Montreal. Let my brother showed
me because he's a huge fan of yours.
I now am two. Oh, that's great. Thank you.
I think this is a very
important time in F1.
This sport is going to continue to move
into the mainstream because the stars in
the sports and the storylines
of competition are starting
to match the popular
culture of today. Oh, that's very, uh, uh,
what's the word?
All I can think of is acetate.
That's a very astute analization.
Is that the word?
I know it can be very Shakespearian.
I appreciate you talking about
the drivers with respect.
Even if you're not a fan of
everything they do is incredible.
How talented these men are in.
Some women are able to navigate it.
Some women are able to navigate
with precision. That's hilarious.
Um,
little chauvinism there.
I would like very much to see you at more
racist and perhaps talking to drivers
and Cruz. Thank you. And bless
your family. Yo, you and me both.
Oh look who's here.
A lovely Nia and my lovely daughter.
You know what?
She has the cutest on today.
She has all these gray sweatpants
and pants with this matching Hoodie,
that short sleeve. It looks like
you got a little Bella check. Hi,
how are you? How was
your breakfast? You know,
see you rant and rave and scream and
yell and your podcast for Damn near 15
years. And you know, I never say anything.
And then I'm having breakfast with our
lovely daughter and we're laughing and
we're joking or singing songs.
And you have the nerve to come in and
tell us to keep it down a cup of cheese.
I know. No, I'm just, uh, yeah,
but this is also putting a roof
over our head. What's up buddy?
How you doing? We can have fun today. Huh?
The itsy bitsy spider.
What went off the wall is about game.
Was
okay in the sun and dried
up all the way and you get,
see bitsy spider went up this bout again.
Yay.
Aww.
Look at that smile. All right. You want
to read some of these with mania? Sure.
Okay. What do we got here? Um, I, yeah,
I absolutely would love
to talk to the driver.
This guy say saying he's from Portugal,
he now lives in Monaco.
How much is this guy
crushing it? Oh, and this is,
listen to what he says about
female drivers near let's say this.
He says it's incredible how talent these,
these men are and some women are
able to navigate with position.
Oh, thanks. Thanks for that.
Some women are, what, what,
where's he going with us?
He was just saying that he would love
to see me talking to more drivers and
being at more, more racist. Oh,
well I know you would like that.
I would love that.
And I think if I could navigate with
precision down to the pit area and if you
don't trip and fall because
you're a woman, right?
Yeah. Yes. I'm a chauvinist
pig and I attract these people.
They need a pot chauvinists needs
podcast too. All right, let's,
let's talk about 45 she liked records,
right? Huh? Yes I do. Hey Sweetie,
you want to talk about 40 fives
huh?
Okay.
You're gonna tell us the story.
What's so crazy right now?
She totally has obviously has all these
thoughts and she knows what she's saying,
but she doesn't understand that we don't
talk her jibberish so she'll just be
sitting there making all
these hand movements,
like she's making these profound
points and she's going, I shake shack
and she's still making,
was she still into that noise that
she can check crap that she was doing?
She's really trying to say words
now. Okay. Can you say baby babies?
A baby?
Oh, there you go. She said so
you liked that frog and it break.
But they do number Michigan. All
right. 40 fives. A Billy burr hole.
A long time fan of the podcast.
Well thank you.
I traveled a lot in your Massachusetts
vibes. Always remind me of home. Uh,
recently. Don't touch that. Don't touch
that. Don't touch that. Um, recently.
Um, it's so funny. They
always go for like,
the thing that's going to hurt them
the most is all this stuff here. Shoes,
chairs and all that. Goes
right for the hot tea. Uh,
recently my fiance and I surrendered
our weekend nights to playing card games
alongside tasty beers at home.
I should just playing 45.
That sounds like fun. Yeah, we
were just saying how we hate those.
Like you go to those parties with
other adults and they have game night,
so he's fucking cards against
humanity and all of that stuff.
I don't want to do that. Um, but we've
got to get to bring back cards. Right.
But isn't that a game? That's a
game night. If you play cards you,
but cards are cool.
It's not like playing mad libs.
I like cards against humanity though.
I feel like if you get kind of high or
a little bit drunk, Adolf Hitler's Tate
good jokes and cards against humanity
are as bad is when you fly southwest.
I hate to make fun of them
cause I loved that airline.
But listening to those people do comedy,
I just can't,
I get angry at the people encouraging
them through. This guy was Sydney,
we were going down the uh,
you know,
we're going down the runway like what?
Go on the tarmac or whatever and
he's doing the Darth Vader voice.
Everybody put on your feet belt.
No,
it just annoys me that that person doesn't
get heckled cause it's just like if I,
if I did a joke like that,
people would be throwing their chair at
me and this guy's getting laughs because
I feel like maybe people feel
obligated because it's the,
the flight crew and you want to be on
their good side. It's exactly what it is.
It's the awkward silence
and people are just in,
in the silence of the joke bombing
people then laugh because they feel
uncomfortable because this is overall
nervousness that what we're about to do
could kill us. Right. So then the
level of comedy that they have to do,
you know what I mean? When you're
scared, you'll laugh at anything.
You just walk in like the rain's
really coming down, isn't it?
It's like you didn't say
anything funny there.
Wow. That was close. Nervous
laughter. There we go. Uh,
I suggest playing 45, which I
know Nia. Are you kidding me? No,
that'd be cool. We got it. We got,
we got to get a cool stereo man.
Well, yeah. You know what?
We should have our own kind of like
night, you know, and music and you and me.
Why don't we do, yeah,
let's sing some songs.
Hug and kiss a little bit
where the little ones down.
Why don't we do that instead
of sitting there going, yeah,
I liked it. Yes. Could
have said that. Cars again.
Hairy asshole. Ooh. Ooh.
I think southwest writes those
punch lines on those stupid cards.
I just don't like that.
You don't write the punchline and
then you get credit for it. I'm sorry,
I'm too, until when did they jump too far
deep into the joke? Gay Man. Yeah, right.
I don't know. Anyways, we could
hardly find any rule. Okay.
I suggest playing 40 fives which I can,
which I had always played
growing up on the north shore,
uh,
in trying to find the rules online.
I was surprised to learn that it's pretty
endemic to Massachusetts. What rules?
What are we talking about? Oh, we
thought he met at 45 as an records.
What is fives? It's obviously some
kind of game that we don't know about.
We thought you were talking about right?
They don't know about 45 it's like you
don't know what acetate means. I guess so.
Yeah. We can hardly friend.
Can you do me a favor?
Can you say acetate three times in a row
with a pause and just no life in your
voice between each one? Just pause. Just
say acetate three times in a row. Okay.
Acetate. Acetate. Slower
acetate. No, I meant longer.
Pause. That was pretty good. Okay.
We'll definitely call you back for
the audition. So what was his thing?
We can hardly find the rules anywhere.
In any case,
just curious whether you ever played
this game growing up or had any other
traditions you found to be a
Massachusetts thing once she left.
Thanks and hope you can come to Vermont
or Montreal sometime soon. Okay.
Yes and yes. Oh, I'm so old. I
thought you said buy records.
That's what I thought it was.
Because somebody gave me some records
in Tulsa and then they aren't.
One of them was a 45. Um, so many I have
to get the adapter. Yeah, I don't know it.
Watch it. Watch it. Watch it.
No, you just, when you're just,
you just want to spill
that, don't you? All right.
40 45 game.
Yeah. Senior game. Hold on a second. Yeah.
40 fives game 45 it's a card game.
Yeah,
that's what I figured.
All right.
Why is my Internet's so slow?
The Ace of heart is
always the best third box.
I was playing with a regular deck
of cards. This isn't like old maid.
You guys remember old maid,
you know,
and then the classic that I never
played granny fucking water.
There's another Cape, there's
another card game. Nia did.
Everybody in the Midwest knows about,
uh,
euchre and that game would Joe Barton,
Nick and j law had talked about card.
They were like freaking out.
They were just going like entire families
had stopped talking to each other on
Christmas because of that game. That
game is evil. That's like a Pittsburgh,
Cleveland, Detroit, that type of
area. I think people play euchre.
The ace of hearts is always the third
best. Trump. Yeah. Week. This is good.
This is good. Clean Fun here. The deal,
robbing the Trump object of the game.
The goal is to accumulate the
most chips by winning tricks.
How to keep score irregularities to do
this. This is, this is a game night bill,
so I don't know why you're talking
about you're so against the game night.
This is what, because I don't like, you
know what? I don't like the modern games.
I'll play cards.
My grandmother was a Bozo and
amazing and my aunt against humanity.
Do you ever play flinch? No flinches
another one. Uh, I, maybe we can. What?
You're going to get all these card games.
Have you ever played spades as a
black people play? Uh, oh, look at me.
Do you have a play hearts?
That's what white people play.
No.
Oh, we got, we got to get some
cards now. We got to get some cars.
We explore each other's like
heritage through card games. Yeah.
You teach me spades.
I got to remember how to play hard.
I don't know how to play spades.
I've maybe played it.
I knew black people's
like Domino's. Well, no,
we're not talking about Domino's.
We're talking about a card game.
I know we're not talking about Domino's.
Why could you just give me that?
That I actually knew something that
was like the Chappelle show sketch.
I know black people. Dominoes
is, come on. I just said,
okay. Jesus. Fuck. Okay.
Sorry. She's so protective.
She's so protective of her culture.
You know that Nia market this little,
oh, you kissing the baby. Oh yeah.
Why are you so protective? We just
want to start an argument. You know,
why are you so protective of your
culture? Well, you let me in.
You've never taught me how to
taught me how to do let you in.
As good as say, you never
taught me how to do the, uh,
do you know Nia could do the whole
Janet Jackson Rhythm Nation Dance? No.
Miss you much. Yeah.
Yeah. That's the thing.
She'll just bust that out out
of fuck. Sorry. Out of nowhere.
And she could really do it. You
know what I mean? It's not like me.
I could do like the peewee Herman
dead, dead dead. A dead end.
I think I'm all impressed.
Okay.
Oh Damn. All impressive. Right. China's
surveillance. Oh, Neil, you know,
people are going to ask you
to fucking Instagram that.
I know it's not going to
happen. No. Okay, I'm back.
Sorry. The, uh, the batteries just died
on this thing. Um, all right. We are,
I think I'm well over an hour
here at this point. I have to be,
I don't really know where I'm at at this
point. All right. Shyness. Surveillance,
man. All right. If, if, uh,
you want me to just do the rest of this
because it seems like she's getting
ready to, uh, run around here, so I don't,
I just don't know if that's going to
be annoying to people to hear go home.
I but I. Dot. I love is I'm sitting
talking about all this stuff,
the doorbell to them as it is. Yeah.
That's the one thing you got to remember.
Your kid is adorable to you. Everybody.
Everybody thinks the kids are adorable.
Then after awhile it's just
like, okay. Oh, okay. Okay. Um,
China's surveillance, dear
bill, Bunker Hill. I love it.
I'm a software engineer. Makes sure she
doesn't shut her hands in the door there.
Um, oh, down like a ton of bricks.
It is amazing that they always
fall in there, but yeah.
All right buddy.
Okay.
All right, Cutie Pie. I'll see
you in a few minutes. Bye Bye.
Oh, all right. I'll see you lovely
ladies out there. All right.
I'm a software engineer
and system integration
specialists at a prominent firm
in a major city.
I won't stay my political affiliation
because I know you hate that move as much
as I do. Good. Let's get into it.
I'm terrified that my children will
have little to no privacy in their adult
lives.
Being in tech,
I'm becoming aware of the capabilities
and advances in surveillance systems and
as an ordinary human
being with the Internet,
I've maintained an understanding that
our government under both parties have
been constantly expanding
their surveillance reach
and continue to lie to us
about what information is being
stored. Yeah, it's ridiculous.
And all the major fucking news
organizations don't say anything about it.
They don't do anything to protect us.
They just sit there fucking making money.
Uh, China isn't very different. Uh,
it's definitely more
aggressive and more intrusive.
The biggest is what Snowden
was trying to warn us about.
We all left that guy twisted on the vine
and everybody was afraid because they
wrapped what this guy was doing and to
trying to beat Isis. So then it was like,
well,
I can't say anything because then I don't
support the troops and then I'm going
to get the Dixie chicks
fucking treatment. Um, that's,
that's all that's all they're
fucking doing right now.
That just destroying people individually.
Um,
just snowed is a fucking
hero as far as I'm concerned.
God Damn fucking lunatics. It's like how
much more do they need to know about?
You just sat down at the airport,
you go through fucking security.
Then it's like you don't
understand in that now go now,
go through Tsa gotta answer all this shit
and get fucking fingerprinted and now,
now that line's clogged up.
So now the next one,
people will fucking stick in
that goddamn retinas in there.
It's unbelievable.
All right.
Drop your pants and spread your butt.
Cheeks is going to be the next one. Don't
get through the line fucking quicker.
And people would do it because
there'll be more convenient. All right.
The biggest differences that they have
the decency to not try and hide it or
maybe you think it's better to
be lied to? I don't know. Well,
I think it's because China could
just fucking, you know, I don't,
as far as I know in mainland China,
you're the level of rights that you
have versus what you have over here.
I think over here you have to lie because
they don't have the right to do what
they're doing. Probably, I dunno,
this article lays out the way in which
our government surveillance is going to
be able to access everything
in a Chinese citizens life,
both at work and at home,
um,
in which government and our government,
one of the most important advancements
being made is not just the collection of
data,
but the sorting
or of data and the ability to sift
through billions of communications for
specific content.
This is why the FBI and CIA have had
information on terrorist activity,
but had no way to access it if
through all the bullshit. Yeah.
So the thing is, so what people will
say, well, as well as least as Lou,
as long as I'm not out there trashing
a, you know, saying I'm a Muslim,
I won't have a problem, uh, back to my
kids more. I, because this is the thing,
they're going to use that to then access
all this other shit as they always
still as they always
do. Um, back to my kids.
Most government technology eventually
makes it, makes its ways to the public.
When my children are in their adult life,
all of their previous years will be
stored somewhere to create a case against
them based on the person that they
were and not who they've become.
Jesus Christ.
That last statement,
there might be most intelligent
thing anybody's ever sent in. Um,
I will send you guys, um, this,
this link to this story and read it and
it just be informed and know that you're
going to be all right.
All right.
Cause I don't want to send
all this doomsday shit
that's gonna make you go into
a depression,
but you also do need to know.
It would be nice if people knew what
was going on and uh, I think like, uh,
this is a time where people,
I just feel like everybody wants to
start speaking up like what are we doing?
And not in an anti USA fucking way,
but you know,
at some point somebody has to
kind of step up here. You know,
I think we kind of need to look at
the finances of how much is fucking
non-ending war is costing us.
And uh,
at some point we're going to
have to pay all of that back.
$700 billion a fucking year.
I mean, I, I, we're really,
we would really be a sad thing if 3,500
fucking jerk offs that train on a jungle
gym were to bankrupt this great nation.
They made some point. We do have to,
there has to be a way to discuss that
without somebody yelling at you saying you
don't support the troops just to, you
know, cause maybe they haven't worked out.
Maybe there was a solution.
It would be nice as a citizen
who's paying ungodly taxes, who would like
to see them go to some shit over here,
like pup making public schools good again.
You know,
maybe get some people off the streets
that need some help. You know,
baldies shutter island,
people fucking walking around.
They used to have facilities
that they could go to.
You combine that with the fact that they
can now go in and buy a bazooka and not
have to wait longer than three fucking
minutes and all of a sudden he started to
have some problems.
You fucking call me mother
fucker. Don't bring that up. Uh,
why did I blame myself for
that? You know, that's not true.
I should sound like I've got to get a
good, good, good corporation impression.
You're clearly against the
United States of America. Um,
wife believes in ghosts. Oh
Jesus, Dear Billy Burger basket.
Uh, I love my wife dearly in on
most topics we are in agreement,
but recently something has come between
us. She believes in ghosts and I do not.
Oh Dude, fucking let it
go. Who gives a shit? Okay.
As long as she's not trying to talk to
them and acting like Whoopi Goldberg and
saying that they're entering her body.
But even then if she does that,
to just dedicate one of your rooms to
that and just have her fucking make money
off of other dopes that believe
what she's doing is real anyways.
I'm not so bothered by her
belief. Sure. It's a bit Kooky,
but she's free to do it and so it's not
hurting anyone. All right. There you go.
The problem is, is that she's offended
that I don't believe in ghosts as well.
Oh Gee, look at that. I gave you a
lecture and you were already fucking,
you were already where I was
telling you to go. It's like, okay,
you believe in ghosts. Good for
you. But I don't fine. Well,
cross. Is there anything
worse than cold tea? Sorry.
Just started confident how to
take a little swig there. Um,
I stopped believing in
ghosts around the same time.
I stopped believing in Santa Claus and
the Easter Bunny back when I was a kid.
So when a full grown adult
tells me they see spirits,
I can't help but wonder if there's
something wrong with them. Mentally.
She is afraid to go to the restroom at
a certain restaurant in our town because
it's a story about it being haunted.
She says the last time she went in there,
she felt an Erie chill,
but it's a draftee bathroom in a 90 year
old bill building for Christ's sake.
She also has this old photograph she
took through a window at an abandoned
mental hospital that she claimed
shows a ghost face. When I look at it,
I only saw blurry bullshit.
I tried to be nice about it,
but I think she felt like I was calling
her stupid or crazy when I didn't see it,
when I didn't see it too.
I didn't want to lie about it besides,
she would know if I was lying.
Anyways,
I don't know how to approach
this topic without upsetting her.
Do you have any advice
for me? Yours truly, um,
this guy left his fucking name. I don't
know if this is a reference to somebody,
uh, at a movie. Let me see.
Yes, this has gotta be somebody's,
uh, this has to be a movie joke.
Okay.
Oh, doctor Peter Venkman. Oh, okay.
This was bill Murray's
character and Ghostbusters.
Okay. Hilarious. All right. Um,
I don't know how to approach
this topic without upsetting her.
Do you have any advice for me? Yours
truly Dr Peter Venkman? Uh, yeah,
don't bring up these topics.
Don't bring up the topic and uh,
you know, I, I would just,
I would just be like, look,
I get it. You believe in ghosts and
I don't, uh, don't say it like that.
Just feel like I respect the
fact that you believe in ghosts
and um,
I don't,
and if the tables were turned and there
was something that I believed in and you
didn't,
I would respect the fact that you didn't,
and a rather than do, you know,
getting upset with you. Okay.
You see ghosts. Evidently you are born
with the power that I was not giving.
So you should feel thankful for that,
that you're able to see these things.
I am a mere mortal. I'll don't say that
cause then that's passive aggressive.
I'm the worst. Something along
those lines. It just say, listen,
I love everything about
you and we get along great.
But I just feel like there's
this tension about this that Eh,
that you're trying to force me to feel
something that I don't feel and I don't
think that that's what you
do to somebody you love.
And I wouldn't do that to you.
Okay.
So come on over here and if
there's not a ghost between us,
could you give me a hug?
Some along those lines?
All right, last one here.
My sister's friend. Oh boy.
Hi Bill. Hi Bill. You can't,
I'm an 18 year olds from England and I
need some advice. All right. You're pasty,
crooked teeth dose around two months ago,
one of my sister's childhood friends
came to visit her for a weekend.
They'd been friends since they were three
and she moved five hours away when she
was 12 so they barely
see each other anymore.
They were playing to go out on
Saturday with a group of friends say,
and I was planning on staying home alone.
Well,
my sister went to pick up a few of
her friends to meet at our house.
Me and her friends flirted a bit,
but nothing major.
We exchanged snapchats, et cetera. I
love how that's flirting now, long,
long story short,
my sister's friend pretended to be ill
and came home early so we could hook up.
Dude, you are fucking crushing it.
Your sister's bringing them home to,
you know you have to go out.
Good for you.
The only thing was my sister was genuinely
ill and also came home early around
30 minutes after her friend and she
caught us in bed together. Well,
what the fuck is she doing
walking into your bedroom.
Okay.
My sister got insanely angry and
stormed out by you should said, hey,
don't hate the player.
Hate the game.
And it just lit a cigarette.
Oh my God.
I think this is fucking funny.
This is fucking hilarious,
dude. Do you realize how hard you're
crushing it? You're fucking at home.
You're not even trying to get late.
She just says her friends come
over for the bullshit. Okay ladies,
you ready to go out and in that moment,
whatever the fuck you
did made one of them,
pretend be sick and come back
and hook up with you. Dude,
you're a fucking hero.
Okay?
There's no reason to get, oh, I don't
care how mad you assistant gets. Just,
I would just keep smiling and just
be like, hey, I can't help it man.
You know the ladies love
me sweetheart, sweetheart.
I wasn't trying to hook up.
I was at home.
I was innocent. I can't help it.
If women are attracted to me,
I would just go totally fucking
arrogant at the matter she get.
I would just keep laughing and I
would never take it seriously. Uh,
my sister has suffered with depression
and anxiety. I forget what, I just,
I didn't see that part.
My sister has suffered with depression
and I'm so excited for you that I didn't
even read this next book. She suffered
with depression and anxiety for years.
So whenever something like this happens,
my family almost always sides with her.
Oh,
that's easy. Then you just divide
and conquer with you, with your dad.
Just be like, Dad, I can't help but I,
I inherited your charisma. What do you,
what do you want from me?
She, I didn't go out with,
she came home to me if
it fell right in my lap.
What was I supposed to do?
Yeah,
they don't and he'll, I don't, I,
there's no fucking way I get mad
at my kid in the morning. I mean,
he's mad because you're making her upset,
but he's not mad at what you did.
I'm guaranteed your dad's
telling his friends at work.
It's fucking son of a bitch and you have
to leave the fucking house to come to.
They come in to him.
Uh,
in the morning she threatened to
never talk to me again for what I did,
but I said something along the lines
of I feel a connection with her
or some bullshit like that to calm my
sister down. The thing was I didn't,
but her friend did.
Oh No.
We started dating and after round two
weeks I re I realized that I fucking hated
this girl. She is generally stupid as
shit. Yeah, dude, this is all good.
This is all good stuff because
you're learning lessons,
which is supposed to in
life, especially at 18. Okay.
This whole thing started with a lie.
Okay.
And that you did to protect
your sister's feeling.
So you just got to come clean.
You've got to dump the dummy
and just tell her like, listen,
I love you so much that I actually
started dating somebody that is fucking
stupid. All right, I'm sorry you have the,
then she'll get mad that you'll be
like calling her friends stupid.
Are you saying my friends is stupid?
No,
I'm saying that friend that
is a friend of you is stupid.
The other ones seem really smart
and you know, tell all of them.
I wouldn't mind if they fake six and
came home and hooked up with them.
All right. I said I fucking hate you.
This girl, she's generally stupid as shit.
My original plan was to pretend I was
into her for a few months and then when I
go to university,
uh,
in a few months I break up with her
because of the long distance. Do it.
Don't do that because you might
break her heart. All right?
But that's some dumb shit
you do when you're 18. Uh,
that way I'd say my
relationship with my sister and,
and mother and get rid of this stupid
bitch. Hey, hey, hey, hey, hey.
Don't talk about women. You don't need
to talk about him like that. Okay.
Feel lucky that you, you know, you got a
better brain than cheated. Yeah. Don't,
don't play with people's
feelings like that. All right?
Cause I'm telling you right now that you,
that if you're any sort of an actual
human being, uh, breaking someone's heart,
the guilt of that never
fucking goes away. Um, however,
I recently received news that my first
choice university turned me down and my
second choice was the
only one that accepted me.
The problem is she lives 15 minutes away
from my second choice university and
now I don't know what to do.
You got to come clean.
I can't go through university
hitched to a girl I fucking hate,
but I can't afford to risk my relationship
with my family for obvious reasons.
Also,
another girl who I think I generally may
have a connection with recently broke
up with a boyfriend of two years and I'm
pretty sure that if I could, if I could,
we would be dating right now.
Uh,
it also doesn't help that this girl is
a nine out of 10 looking model and I'm
probably a six and a half out
of 10 at best. Thanks for you.
Help you freckled Twat all right.
Through this is what you got to learn.
You're going to learn, uh,
honesty here. All right?
I'm fucking break up
with that woman today.
All right?
And you have to come clean,
okay?
With everybody in your house
and you have to say, you know,
you have to put your foot down that
your parents cannot be choosing.
I would maybe I would have this
conversation with your parents.
They can't be choosing your sister over
you straight across the board because of
your sister's depression
and anxiety issues. Okay.
I don't know how severe they are. All
right. If they're chemical, then yeah,
that's a major problem. But you
know, if she just needs to fucking,
you know, get out of a funk, then I dunno.
I Dunno where she is on the
whole depression spectrum
if that's the proper thing.
But like you shouldn't have to
be suffering like this, dude,
you got to live your own fucking
life, all right? Just live your life.
Live your life,
and when you live your life,
sometimes people are going to get hard.
Okay,
all right, fuck that. Break up with this
woman and go ask the other woman out.
That's it.
That's what the fuck you do and if anybody
in your family has a problem with it,
let them vent to you and
all that stuff and just say,
I'm sorry that I am doing what
my heart is telling me to do.
All right. I am not trying to
hurt anybody in this family.
Had I known that hooking up with that
girl was going to cause this level of of
drama, I wouldn't have done
it. I regret that I did it.
I actually felt so bad that actually
fucking dated or for two weeks the whole
time and it was like
talking to a fucking chair.
Say all this stuff nicely.
Okay.
All right.
There's a woman that I like,
then I want to pursue and I'm going
to do that, and if that's wrong,
that God damn it,
I don't want to be right and walk out,
okay,
and don't let them hold your sister's
fucking problems over your goddamn head
because that's good. Look, we'll
do what it's already doing.
It's causing you to fucking date
people you don't want to date.
So then she's going to be depressed and
you're going to be living this life of
fucking misery because you didn't do what
you wanted. Okay? Now, having said that,
don't call women bitches,
all right? Don't do that.
I'm not saying don't call them out
on this shit and stand your ground,
but the don't don't have a do the name
calling thing, all right? Because it's,
it doesn't die.
It gets you not only does it and it
makes the other person not hear what your
point is,
then they can bring that up for the rest
of your fucking relationship and God
knows they're going to do it. All
right? That's the fucking podcast. Oh,
fuck yourself. I'll check in
on you on Thursday. Bye Bye.